actionpoint in theaters near you
tomorrow about a crackpot owner of a
low-rent out-of-control amusement park
based on an actual place that Mike del
2fo once went as a kid in Vernon New
Jersey action park northern jewel is
here never got hurt but I know people
that were you were one of the few yeah
that emerged unscathed it was also
called class-action Park traction parts
yeah yeah traction Park yeah I do
remember being a kid because I was
across the the the water in Staten
Island New York it's like you got to go
to Great Adventure do not go to action
Park it was like Lord of the Flies but
with booze and weed there were zero
adults and the kids running the rides
were loaded so they didn't care what you
did so Piggy's doing bong hits is that
what you're doing in terms of the way
the Lord of the Flies
yes complete the conch the conch oh my
gosh so then you you read about this
you're like I could do a movie on this
yes how came about my friend and
producer Derek Freitas sent me a
14-minute doc about action Park it's
online you should check it out it's
amazing everyone's telling their stories
about going there and how injured they
gotten out of control was and they have
this glow about them because it was the
best time of their life because they
could do whatever they wanted as long as
they survived it the well there's that
so you thought this is a perfect way for
yeah it's a perfect setting for a comedy
and I can be the owner of the park and I
can test all the rides and I can do
stunts for real and so I asked the stunt
guys and the men and women stunt people
to do the stunts like I did so everyone
was going to concrete and ground and
people were being carried off left and
right on the shooting of this yeah yeah
I got care this is the most injured I've
ever been on a film come on now mmm I
mean we've all seen all the Jackass
movies I see Johnny ghastly like what
how would you hurt then I had four
concussions I broke my hand
tore my meniscus stitches over here
whiplash lost some teeth and then I
broke a bone on my face from one of the
Falls and I didn't realize until I got
back to my room from the emergency room
that I had broken the bone of face
because I blew my nose and my left eye
popped out of its socket on a second
yeah so you blow your nose and then you
feel your left eye come out of your way
past marty Feldman it's coming out what
does that feel like it feels unnatural
what'd ya have to say about this she you
know gets friends and family they they
were happy when this film was wrapped
you know I think they like when I do
pranks but when I do stunts because the
way I do stunts all mine are designed to
fail so it takes a toll on everyone
how'd you break your eye how did that
one happen they said the doctor said I
was off the alpine slide stunt I travel
like 20 feet in the air and I was about
six feet off the ground and I stopped my
forward momentum with my face it gave me
a terrible concussion I couldn't
remember anything for 30 40 minutes
pretty much and they said I had broken
the orbital they said and break it it
disappeared the orbital lamina bone just
disappeared on impact so when I was
blowing my nose I was blowing air behind
my eyeball and pushing it out it
happened twice I'm sorry but just the
matter-of-fact way in which you're you
look great buzz well thank you indeed I
did it right after I look like it looked
like a Picasso painting like this I was
here in this I was way down here it was
really screwed up this is one of those
rare moments in the radio world what I
don't have to reset everyone knows it's
Johnny Nam yeah of course for these what
is the most hurt you've ever been in
anything that you've ever done career
johnny Knoxville I don't know this I
don't know there's been many things but
two of the things that are little odd is
when I broke my penis and then with my
eye
popped out of its socket twice on
actionpoint mm-hmm so do you want to
review the the former rather than the
latter but the the first injury would
say well I think we covered the latter
the former was I was trying to backflip
a motorcycle and and I don't know how to
ride a motorcycle
travis pastrana literally had to let out
the clutch for me and he said just kind
of keep it in low gear until you get to
bobbin ramp and then like give it all
the gas you can and start pulling back
but whatever you do don't let go of the
bike because whatever goes up has to
come down and boy did I not listen I did
that four times on the fourth attempt I
just I let it go he goes 20 feet in the
air and comes back down and breaks his
handlebars off of my crotch and you
broke your manhood that's yeah it's
called yeah I was tore my urethra but it
was I was I felt when I stood up I felt
like I was peeing and and so I looked
and every time my heart would be blood
would shoot out my feet having a fantasy
name now broken Knoxville's torn urethra
dude is there a splint for that I had to
go straight into surgery and I did they
Johnny they taped it to my leg and I had
a tube running all the way down - so I
had to pee that way for several weeks
and the worst part is well I don't know
if I probably shouldn't go there because
I don't know what the rating is on this
show became excited with my leg it taped
onto my leg then it's excited at a right
angle geometry lessons with johnny
Knoxville here on the rich Aussie show
what's that with a Korean theory on that
let's take a break when we come back
Johnny will talk about him coaching
youth baseball here in the Los Angeles
area
true story correct yeah
back in 60 seconds with the star of
action point Kendall is Johnny Knoxville
film action point in theaters near you
starting tomorrow and Johnny Knoxville
back here on the Rich Eisen show now
when you live in the Los Angeles area
you never see who from TV or film is
gonna just show up anywhere supermarkets
schools or on a youth baseball diamond
so a people might be used to that but
what's the reaction when parents bring
their kids the diamond and Johnny
Knoxville is the coach of the team well
I'm just the assistant color the
assistant yes and there's I've been
doing it for a few years so it's just
everything's normal and and it's so fun
you're not teaching headfirst slides no
no I don't want them to get hurt like
with my own kids I'm like a helicopter
parent I don't want really totally if
they do something say something naughty
then I'm like but I do I'm if they're
climbing a tree I'm right under the tree
okay yes you know what can happen pretty
I just don't want to I don't want to see
it so you have not instilled your
daredevil well my son is very he's got
the funny look in his eye like my father
so I'm trying to steer him away from all
that but it's so fun helping coach
baseball are you as a coach you mean
Johnny Knoxville your coaching
philosophy that age there a you spend
not so much time on instruction as
opposed to like yelling no tackling or
no wrestling in the outfield or stop
drawing in the dirt so it's it's
hilarious so you're teaching ready
position focus get out there so just you
realize that just they like they some of
them have trouble throwing yes
and so because what age let's clue
everybody in the way group eight and you
know I always played baseball growing up
is one thing that I was always kind of
decent at yeah and but I never thought
about how I throw you know what are the
and how to teach that so that took I
I'm learning just like them on how to
teach them right so point the glove at
your target yeah I'm up getting your arm
up I don't see Jeff arm up I think I
tell them to start with the knuckles to
the ground and then you know bring it on
around to bring it on around yeah and
follow-through yeah you throw because
some of them just try to do the my son
was doing this catcher's move you're
just bringing it from his ear and he's
got a great arm but I'm like you're
you're not using any of your body you
know so then it's amazing when the balls
hit and an actual put out takes place
Yeah right whether it's one of those Bad
News Bears moments where lupus just
catches the ball and it's just the most
amazing thing happens or somebody feels
it steps on second constant amazing
someone's stealing third and the third
baseman has no clue go straight by his
ear you know it's pop flies are a
miracle in that age so age of what sort
of baseball player were you Johnny
I was a pitcher and first baseman really
yeah so what was your what was your game
as a pitcher it means you throw heat you
were junk ball I had I had a pretty good
fastball and in just a fastball and
curve and that seemed to get me through
high school okay yeah did you get any
any looks he's fryin I love my arm out
my senior year but I could have either
some I could have played college ball
you know there was a couple of I could
probably went to junior college ball and
then to college okay but after that my
arm
I blew it out and then I decided to move
to Los Angeles instead but god I miss
baseball and just playing it or do you
watch it at all or no you're doing I'm
playing it okay you know you know really
a spectator when it comes down to that
stuff I watch a little not as much as I
used to but I love going to the games
mm-hmm I mean I just love coaching
because I'm having more fun than any of
the kids out there
it's so fun well that's good cuz you
have to I mean the kids at age 7 h8 need
to be focused in some way shape we got
to get out there and rally the kids and
have some fun yeah focus is a big thing
and my age does its well we've also just
heard about the number of concussions
you've had Johnny Knoxville here on the
Rich Eisen show and you're more boxing
or MMA which one of you right last we
had John we were talking major prize
fight stuff with you yeah I love boxing
I just watch MMA more these days because
there's so many terrible decisions in
boxing and just they constantly break my
heart and it's like okay I'm gonna give
it one more chance and then you'll have
the Goblin Canelo Alvarez decision and
it just drives me up a wall so you enjoy
have you been to an MMA have you got any
with UFC or anything no no I haven't
been to a fight but I watch them all the
time I buy them constantly okay and
their decisions seem to be pretty good
but isn't it the Nevada stay at like a
mission no Thames well I mean he's built
do the same judges or do you think most
of the men did submission anyway well
somebody beaten to a bloody pulp when it
all comes down to it why can't they like
post the results after each round like a
baseball game the judges you know make
people responsible like that cuz it's
all like a sheik like you don't know
what's going on and then you get this
one-sided jaw like where is this judge
coming from you and it's like a eight
point different from the other judges
maybe you should get Conor McGregor in
your next movie well yes yeah well he
would be great because I mean he he
loves the camera and he's good on camera
he strike he strikes me like is a
character from a guy ritchie movie yeah
he's tall the Two Smoking Barrels let
walk he's got that whole Vinnie Jones
thing yeah when I think and he's kind of
got that that charisma he's eat up with
charisma so how much longer you gonna do
this Johnny the interview I mean your
career where you're throwing your body
all over I know that there's only so
many chances I can take you know hmm
because I have one of my stunts I don't
know how they're gonna end I know it's
gonna in bad but I don't know how okay
so so what's next I don't know I've been
developing a couple of other movies and
just taking a break from stunts for a
second just because of all the
concussions I think that's a wise
maneuver Johnny one of my one of my few
and you're not going to the big slick
this year because your movies over
tomorrow right I wish I was going to the
big slick it's a wonderful event
benefits the Children's Mercy Hospital
in Kansas City and I just can't do it
this I know you and that's where you and
I once we had an early flight the next
morning after the big event and we both
took a cab ride together back and the
cabbie said he needed to stop for gas
and stopped off in the sketchy gas
station at like 1:30 in the morning yeah
and I remember just the difference that
this is the difference of the way we're
both wired I'm thinking of myself like
oh man what the hell is gonna happen and
you thought the night is just we both
reacted differently to the whole
situation yeah I like when things get a
little weird I need that a little I need
a little bit of that in me maybe I
should just be catapulted through a barn
once and just get it out of my system
can make that applica Johnny hey
Congrats on the movie man thank you it's
a funny funny movie it's kind of like an
old-school 80s type it's like yeah like
a little bit there's a little bit of
meatballs yeah there you know what's bad
news bears a lot before you know helping
to write the movies really yeah bad news
bears all of them including bringing the
London plague bad news bears in Japan
yeah that was it that was the third one
yeah yeah no I just the first one
Buttermaker one yeah okay yeah that was
it still holds up it's brilliant some of
those movies don't like I watched
Caddyshack again and as much as I loved
it it doesn't hold up like Bad News
Bears because there's like a real story
there mm-hmm so in the action points for
all its insanity there's a real story
there I'm trying to save my theme park
and the relationship with my 14 year old
daughter so there is there's that side
of it too
yes this is a nice old school of
feel to this movie action point in
theaters new you June first come back
anytime thank you good to see you in one
piece Johnny Knoxville here on the
Richardson show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience